in the last video we introduced
ourselves to the law of supply and it
was a fairly common sense idea that if
we hold all else equal that if the price
of something goes up there's more
incentive for more producers to produce
it or a given producer to produce more
of it and we saw that as the price goes
up we moved along the supply curve and
the quantity produced went up now what I
want to talk about in this video is all
the things we held equal in the last
video and the first of these I'll call
this the price price of inputs or
another way to think about it is the
cost of production so if the price of
inputs maybe the price of labor the
people who would have to pick the grapes
or our fuel that we need to transport
the grapes or the land if any of that
increased that at a given price point we
would make less money there's less
incentive for us to do it especially if
it's this is true only for grapes maybe
we'll say ok if it's now more expensive
to get grape seeds maybe I'll start
planting something else because I'm not
getting as much profit per pound of
grape so if the price of my inputs or
for my the price of my car or the 50 if
the size of my costs go up at any given
price point I'd want to produce less so
if my price puts the price of inputs go
up my supply the supply would go down so
if this becomes at this price point I'd
make less money so I would produce less
or maybe I would produce other things so
this would I would [ __ ] the whole supply
curve would shift would shift to would
shift to the left and also even the
minimum price I would need to supply any
of it would also go up when you shift
the curve to the left because now all of
a sudden it costs me more to produce
even that first unit and likewise if my
price of my inputs went down now all of
a sudden at any given price point
producing grapes would become more
profitable and I would have more
incentive to maybe produce grapes
relative to other things and use more
land for grapes than other things and
then you would have the whole curve
shift to the right now let's think about
now let's think about related goods so
what happens with the price of related
good
and we have to put our when we think
about this we don't want to think of it
from a demand point of view because
we're talking about supply you want to
think about it from the producers point
of view so when we think about related
Goods here we want to think about
substitutes for production so maybe I'm
a farmer and I know very little bit
about farming so I don't know this as
possible
but maybe on my land I'm saying well
some of my land is going to be for
grapes and some of it is going to be for
blueberries and so what would happen if
the if the price of a related good in
particular blueberries what if what
would happen if the price of blueberries
went up well if the price of blueberries
went up then I would say wow you know
maybe I can do better with blueberries
and I would allocate more of my land to
blueberries than to grapes and so once
again if the price of related goods is
well it depends which related Goods but
if the price of productive substitutes
so price of other things I could produce
other things I can produce if the price
of other things I can produce goes up
goes up then my supply of grapes
once again my supply of grapes would go
down and the important thing is is in
any of these circumstances literally
just think it through do not just look
at what I'm writing here and just try to
memorize in some form way shape or form
these this is really just a way to think
about things hey obviously if I can make
more money off of blueberries now all of
a sudden I'm going to allocate more of
my land to blueberries then to grapes
supply of grapes will go down now let's
think about what happens with the number
of suppliers number of suppliers and
this one is this is pretty common sense
the more people they are supplying the
higher the supply would be so the
numbers of so if the number of suppliers
goes up and now you wouldn't imagine
this is a curve maybe for the aggregate
supply so if the number of suppliers go
up then the aggregate supply would go up
at any given price point if the number
of suppliers were to go down then the
aggregate supply would go down at any
given price point so this one hopefully
is somewhat obvious then we could think
about things like technology
and so this is just maybe there's some
innovation some new type of seed that
get with the same amount of work the
same amount of land can produce that
many more grapes so if you have
technological improvements so
technological improvements I'm assuming
we're not going to go into some type of
Dark Ages and we have technological
improvements then that will that will
also make the supply that will also make
the supply go up you can also think of
it as it might make it cheaper to
produce so it's kind of the same thing
here the price of inputs might go down
so that would make your supply go up or
you could just say hey look there's just
going to be more grapes popping off of
these new types of vines that we got so
we're just going to produce more grapes
and then the last one I'll cover and
it's a little bit strange in the grape
analogy is the expected future prices so
the expected future prices expected
future prices price expectations and
let's take let's go away from the grapes
because grapes are they're perishable
goods they go bad it's not like you can
save goods to Purdue to to use them
later but if let's say you are an oil
producer and oil is something that you
can store and you can use it later if
you expected oil prices if you expected
oil prices to be neutral today and then
tomorrow all of a sudden you are sure
that oil prices are going to go up in
the future you're sure that a year from
now oil prices are just going to go
through the roof what's your incentive
well you should hoard all of your oil do
not sell it today and wait to sell it in
the future if you're sure that's what's
going to happen so if you expect expect
you if you're if you if there's a change
in expected future prices so if you go
from from neutral to expecting prices go
up prices go up in the future then
you're going to hoard your goods you
can't hoard grapes because the grapes
will just go bad you might be able to I
don't know turn them into wine or
something but if we're talking about
something like oil you would say hey why
should I pump all of the fixed amount of
oil in the ground today to sell it at
today's lower prices I'm going to I'm
going to lower the supply today and so I
can sell it in the future so if the
expected future prices go from
you kind of your neutral to you expect
future prices to go up dramatically then
current supply and that's I'm just going
to emphasize by writing the word current
current supply current supply will go
down so you can hoard it to sell it in
the future